[Music]
you were good friends with Diana what
would she think of Megan Marco well
she's not too happy about it because she
thinks it's going to end in disaster
Simone claims to speak to Diana from
beyond the grave she says she and Diana
used to meet at Kensington Palace five
times a week and played for me some of
the many phone messages Diana left for
her
Diana's psychic tells me the late
princess is concerned that Harry's
marriage to Megan will create a lot of
pain she doesn't want to see her hurt
because he won't be able to cope with
that level of emotion and distress so
she thinks that Megan will hurt him yes
in what way she thinks that a few years
down the line Megan well she'll get very
bored with Harry she's gonna have eyes
for somebody else
Simone believes Megan is more in love
with the spotlight than she is with her
prince she's not really looking into
Harry's eyes and sinking in like William
and Katie Perry you can see is totally
beguiled she looks at her diamond ring
all the time do you think Harry and Meg
it'll have children yes how many but
definitely going to have one possibly
two Simone showed me some of the
affectionate cards the Princess of Wales
sent her and claims Diana is watching
over her grandchildren little George
Charlotte and Louie she's quite happy
she goes and talks to the children the
children think she's like a little angel
she adores them oh but Simone believes
Harry should heed the advice
Diana's giving him she would have said
Harry protect that heart of yours mummy
doesn't want to see you hurt
now one other interesting point from
Simone she believed that if Harry's mom
and dad Diana and Charles had married
just five years later that they still
might be together today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]